a big time hey what up we're here my
little sweaty let's go swim for us I'm
gonna go down to gonna head down the
Hanalei Bay show from the water
beautiful North Shore of Kauai got a
nice morning literally rains on and off
on the North Shore of Kauai so I've got
to take the sunny sky when you can and
we're gonna bring you on this little
lush adventure and we're gonna check in
with you along the way
all right here we are
epic five North Shore of Kauai right
Hanalei Bay and I think you would be
hard-pressed to find a place where's the
pool we doubling down on the on the flip
cam double dipping I said so here's the
pullout and I said you could see a
waterfall up I'm at the mountain and
it's really quite extraordinary here so
super blessed to be here and we're gonna
jump in the water and get a little swim
done what do you think about why I think
that the optimal word for Kauai North
Shore quiet least epic other than epic
is lush it's unbelievably lush air so
anyway
do you know hey so check it out
well doggone I just finished day five of
the epic five I mean wait what do we do
it's Friday grant got a job we got
nothing to do
all right Saturday morning Jason and I
are headed out early do a four-hour ride
in the north side of the island down all
the way to the south east corner where
the road ends so we just left the condo
but we've got a little beautiful morning
here it's real damp up here in the North
Shore
it's got to be careful the roads are
always a little wet and slick so err on
the side of caution right
it's gonna be beautiful bring you inside
our world today we're gonna try and go
down and watch the finish line up the
Hawaii Olympic triathlon first-ever down
in Livia Hui Hui it's a little local
triathlon their first one in our Eric is
a legend he's a definite challenge world
champion somewhat the decades 10 Ironman
think he did it in 12 days sleep and
he's also a mammal champion pretty much
ruled the 90s in the old world it's done
Bram it's got a wealth of information he
just wrote an interesting article on
this month's inside triathlon magazine
it's a scientist who works with
astronauts and aerospace
yeah he's got some interesting
information you guys should check out
his article on this one for all its
ultra dudes out there need to constantly
be aware of our body basically you had a
bad crime in Clearwater
a fire and world champions and chefs
clap got a car behind do you wanna buy a
gyro from me and I got what am I gonna
do with the gyro and he goes you can
make it ethics is reading my shirt and
I'm like talking about a homeless guy
yeah but you gotta you gotta you got to
know that the quality of life for the
homeless dude in Hanalei I'll check it
out with a funny thing stay out of the
rain so it's Sunday morning
homily a day we're gonna go for a little
ocean swim our ocean swim kick off the
day shot day up here
no public access
anyway another beautiful morning in
Kauai and we're a couple days out from
the event because they're run around
today take care of a bunch of stuff get
organized and do a p.m. round the
night's check in with you later